vont le public jeudi oui bien sûr mais
l'ensemble des médias s'ils se taisaient
ne ferait que le prix concours ne serait
rien c'est vous ces autres qui ont qui
en fait ce qui l'a tant mieux d'ailleurs
vous parliez d'argent un écart il faut
parler argent reproduit concours alors
qu apporte exactement le prix goncourt
en écrivain la fortune quels changements
bon ou mauvais dans sa carrière
extrêmement différent sur les candidats
selon les années ecoutons-les justement
écoutant à l'ancien candidat michel
tournier que serge richeze a voulu
interroger justement pour obtenir une
réaction
michel tournis alors qu'est ce que vous
a apporté le prix goncourt le prix
glomma d'avoir rapporté comme à tous les
lauréats du prix goncourt
une récompense de 50 francs voilà voyez
c'est un chèque que j'ai gardées j'aime
mieux vous dire que c'est une relique on
se garde bien que le l'envoyer à la
banque on le met sous verre parce qu'il
faut que vous sachiez que quand le
premier prix goncourt a été donné en
1903 ça me faisait pas vendre un seul
exemplaire le plus mais il y avait un
chèque de 5000 francs or qui permettait
à l'époque de vive très très bien un an
et passablement deux ans et c'était la
récompense
et puis alors disons en 80 ans n'est ce
pas l'argent a fondu à fondue a fondu et
la récompense a jamais bougé
ça fait aujourd'hui 50 francs au niveau
des droits d'auteur je pense que vous
nous aidera d'auteur le prix goncourt
vagin entre 200000 et six cent mille
exemplaires ce qui fait entre 1 million
et 4 millions de choix le public croit
souvent que ça apporte un petit peu
comme le lotto la loterie nationale que
ça apporte le pactole financier c'est
pas ça c'est pas ça parce qu'elle fit ce
que tu es derrière il faut pas se
leurrer mais ce que ça apporte c'est
tout d'un coup nous avertir d'un certain
nombre de portes qui étaient jusque là
fermé l auriez aimé avoir le prix
goncourt deux fois écoutez je vais vous
dire une chose à vous parler évidemment
du problème de romain gary et d'emile
ajar puisque romain gary est le seul qui
a eu le prix goncourt de choix sous le
nom d'emile ajar l'année dernière à
pareille époque je publie un roman
gaspard melchior et balthazar et mes
amis l'académie goncourt ayant reçu il y
en a un qui me dit ah c'est dommage que
tian cela l'auteur ça nous aurait fait
un bon prix longo pour cette année et je
me suis dit mais au fait c'est vrai
pourquoi je n'ai pas fait signer par mon
jardinier ou par ma petite amie
n'est ce pas on aurait partagé les
droits d'auteur évidemment auriez aimé
avoir le prix goncourt ou quoi je crois
que c'est comme les très très belles
choses il faut que ça reste unique avec
notre notre siège est un petit salon
chez drouant où l'on mange
merveilleusement bien et gratuitement en
plus pour l'académie goncourt et je dois
dire que le menu du jour du prix
goncourt est évidemment passablement
vous avez l'exemplaire vous avez oui ce
n'est jamais ça vous allez tous vos
documents j'ai remis tous les documents
voilà j'ai amené le le menu du de
l'année dernière c'était là 691e séance
de l'académie goncourt
je ne vous le dit pas mais si ça vous
amuse de ces sages orinats belga de la
caspienne joie gras d'oie frais en lob à
la gelée à un marbre ou en faisant aussi
en volière des pommes en liard fromage
glacé café et toucha d'édition bien
alors un choix qu'on a assez